hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zur vorstellung von
meinem neuen konzept 2.0
ich werde euch nun erstmal in diesem
video ein paar neuerungen erzählen
natürlich nicht alles ganz im detail
dafür sind dann jeweils die ersten
folgen bzw
die folgenden videos dafür
verantwortlich aber ich werde euch erst
mal einen groben überblick geben das
heißt wenn ihr wissen wollt was so in
der nächsten zeit auf meinem kanal
kommen wird was sich verändert habe was
allgemeinen der späteren zukunft kommen
wird was mit alten projekten sein wird
dann schaut euch dieses video einfach an
lehnt euch zurück trinkt tee und esst
cookies und naja egal ich glaube fest
dass ich meine allgemein das erste mal
und zwar habe ich veränderte texte
beschreibungen verändertes kanal diese
neue form nails neues intro neues auto
veränderte facebook und twitter führung
und auch dort neue design veränderte
video titel veränderte beschreibungen
und ich möchte euch zuschauer mai weiter
in die videos einbeziehen und ich würde
mal sagen mehr einbeziehung der
zuschauer geht eigentlich gar nicht aber
ich komme dann erst mal ganz kurz noch
mal zu den projekten bevor ich dazu
weiter rede und zwar wird es die today
show geben dass es dem das in den mmc
und ich in minecraft und ist quasi so
eine neuauflage des letzten schahs mit
anderen aufbau aber das wird alles in
der ersten folge morgen erzählt die
kommt morgen um 16 uhr online also alle
zwei tage 16 uhr kommt eine folge also
am 9
am 11 13 15 17 19 21 und so weiter jeden
tag 16 uhr kommt eine folge wenn wir so
hinkriegen also das ist so ein richtwert
und den erlebt die folge zu der zeit
auch wir haben eigentlich nur diese
zeiten gemacht weil den hat auch
hochladen müssen wir müssen und welche
zeiten setzen eigentlich mögen wir das
nicht so aber schreibt euch mal so ein
kalender alle zwei tage 16 uhr kommt
eine folge er jeden samstagabend wird
lost kommen das ist ein hardcore let's
play und zwar werde ich mir dort selber
die regeln setzen das heißt ich werde
nicht den hardcore mode spielen sondern
ich werde es in der beta 1.5 spielen ja
in der beta 1.5 die vor einem jahr oder
so draußen war und dass wir die
komplette serie wird ungefähr so 15
allerhöchsten 20 folgen beinhalten blatt
la ich weiß ist allerdings wenig aber
eine folge wird zu 45 minuten lang
sein das heißt bekommt jede woche
samstagabend 45 minuten partner von
bison spielfilm halt im fernsehen habe
ich mir das gedacht und da möchte ich
euch halt auch mit einbeziehen von
themen die ihm in die kommentare
schreiben könnte und so weiter jeden
mittwochabend wird es den kontakt geben
bzw
vielleicht nicht jeden mittwochabend
aber ich sagte dass man einfach so wende
kommt dann immer mittwochs und zwar ist
das sind das news aus der technik gaming
minecraft branche oder halt auch von
youtube
da gibt es eine user partizipation also
dass ihr mir auch sagen können worüber
ich reden soll
und das wird fünf bis zehn minuten
höchstens dauern also wirklich
allerhöchstens da bekommt ihr dann
einfach einmal in der woche so ein paar
kompakte news zusammengepackt wenn neue
sap draußen ist und so weiter das pack
ich dann halt da alles mit rein dann
wird es eine minecraft mythen show geben
da sind ich und ein partner mit dem ich
noch nie etwas vorgemacht habe also
keine beraten wer das sein wird
mit dem stelle ich minecraft bemühten in
einer von uns konzipierten welt vor und
wir untersuchen diese dann von
beispielen und so weiter werden wir
haben erst mal eine folge aufgenommen
und laden die dann jetzt in der nächsten
zeit irgendwann hoch und warten wir die
ankommt und ihr dürft uns dann auch
mythen für weitere folge in die
kommentare schreiben
und werdet dann vielleicht erwähnt also
machen das anhand von der bewertung
abhängig ob wir das weitermachen oder
eher nicht
dann wird es jeden tag eine review bzw
eine schau von den innovativen mit einem
coolen texte bergischen sieht ein update
und so weiter geben zeit läge ich damit
nicht da gar nicht fest einfach täglich
irgendwie sowas das war damals so dass
wirklich so vielleicht mal alle fünf
tage gar nichts kam dann wieder zwei an
einem tag also jeden tag wird es von den
vier sachen geben und was ihr bei
solchen sachen immer machen könnt oder
halt auch bei lost ihr könnt mir euren
minecraft in-game namen zb bei reviews
mai trifft mythen schober lost oder so
in die kommentare schreiben
und vielleicht nehme ich euren skin beim
nächsten video das heißt ich hab da so
ein programm wo ich den teuren minecraft
enorm eingeben dann hab ich den speed
und das ist ein ganz cool wenn man nicht
gerne
guck dir zb ein video und dann auf
einmal der benutzt ja mal ins können
also so also ich hab das ist ganz lustig
naja aber wenn irgendwann halt meine
folge von lost oder dem konto oder eine
show folge oder irgendwie sowas nicht
komplette show dann erfahrt ihr das
immer sofort auf facebook dass es
facebook dort
facebook.com / contractor tv steht auch
unten oben in der beschreibung und so
weiter und da bekommt ihr dann alle
updates
dann gibt es noch ein paar geplante
projekte in der weiteren zukunft also so
ein paar monaten
und zwar sind das live streams ich
versuche live streams zu machen aber ich
sprit kostet mittlerweile geld im
dreistelligen betrag und außerdem ist
meine internetverbindung nicht gerade
die beste aber wenn ich irgendwann
streamen kann dann wird es komplett
werbefrei sein das heißt ich habe kein
verdienst an der sache und ich werden
durchgängig stream ohne
werbeunterbrechungen
was wird gespielt das werden michael
stange games und normal minecraft
gespielt außerdem noch falcon antwort
runden oder mini spiele bei google
chrome oder so aber der hauptgrund für
die live streams wird das singleplayer
let's play sein denn auf youtube wird es
pausiert nicht abgebrochen estate
pausiert ich hab da noch dran aber ich
wollte erst mal dieses lost starten weil
ich es mal so ein altes let's play mehr
lust habe aber ich werde das display
let's play erstmal nur im livestream
weiterspielen und ich werde dann noch
immer videos hochladen waren extreme
aber wenn ihr das verpasst hat seit
bitte nicht böse oder enttäuscht oder so
es gibt die möglichkeit patridge tv das
immer nachzugucken sage ich mal dass die
streams werden da immer aufgezeichnet
aber das werde ich euch alles ganz genau
erklären
wenn es dann so weit ist in ein paar
wochen naja also da nicht traurig sein
es kommt ja dann noch wie lost er dann
wird es bald auch server vorstellungen
geben da werde ich entweder allein oder
manchmal auch mit jemand anderem auf
server gehen mich umschauen will eine
bewertung abgeben und kurz den server
und gebautes zeigen und happy meals wird
erstmal auch weiter aber unregelmäßig
hochgeladen also das war es jetzt
erstmal alles ist jetzt ungefähr so ein
paar grund sachen die neu sind das jetzt
erst mal nach viel chaos an und viele
neue sachen
aber ich denke werdet euch dann relativ
schnell zurechtfinden also wartet
erstmal die nächste woche ab da werden
dann erst mal ganz viele neue videos
kommen und ich hoffe einfach ihr bleibt
mir weiterhin treu ich habe über diese
woche die ich jetzt mehr komplett pause
genommen habe von planungen und alles
mögliche echt wieder eine menge bock auf
videos hat eine menge vorproduziert und
ich hoffe einfach dass wir zusammen spaß
haben werden auf meinem neuen wieder auf
geborenen kanal kalt erhaltung und naja
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr dieses video
bewerten wenn nicht anlass ist einfach
und ich würde mich wie immer über einen
kommentar und eure meinung zu meinem
neuen
konzept freund schau und ach ja was ich
noch sagen könnte es ist ja gerade in
varna mittags und heute abend um 19 uhr
wird mein neues intro online kommen
das heißt da seht ihr wie mein neues
intro dann aussieht und dann bis nachher
chip